Hello, Dr. Kevin Conner's here for your member's minute, sometimes they go more than a minute, but they're fun
So remember we've been talking about Lyme disease. I don't remember. This is the first video I watched
Oh, I don't like my blue marker. We'll go back to red so Lyme disease
chronic Lyme disease
tends to be a
TH1 dominant disorder
What does that mean again? You have two sides of your immune system. TH1 and TH2
This is the marine core. This is the police force. These are the enforcers. This is the
Side of the immune system that makes antibodies
People that have chronic Lyme are not TH2 dominant. So they're TH1 dominant. This side of the immune system is hyperfiring
We put it on a scale like this
They have many more TH1 cytokine circulating in their body than they have TH2
That's the problem. They have a lot of tissue destruction. Here's the irony
When you have the cyclical, you know, you know, if you have chronic Lyme or any chronic disorder like this
You have days that are that are better and days that are just horrible and days that are better and days that are horrible
You probably have to you probably act like you know, I think I think I got this better
I think that stuff. I started taking this better and then two days later you feel like oh my gosh
What did I eat? What did I do? I feel like trying to get I feel like in the dirt again the problem is you
When your immune system is healthy you feel the worst because when your immune system ramps up
You destroy more self-tissue. So when you feel better
It's when your immune system is fatigued. So your immune system is exhausted and fatigued and you go I feel better
Kind of ironic, isn't it? It's because your immune system is thinking that it's doing its job
By destroying self tissue because it's killing what the the tissue that has been tamed the cells have been tamed by antibodies
So the Boralea bacteria hasn't been tamed by antibodies
It's hiding inside the cells and the cells are being destroyed not good
So when you give a TH1 stimulants, there's a list of them in my book
There's more than even the list of the book the help my body's killing me book if you want to download that book for free
It's immune book.com. There's a list of TH1 stimulants, but anything that you think of that as an immune stimulant is really a TH1 stimulant
Don't take them